bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24 heures Sénat dans un instant nous
allons prendre la direction de
l'hémicycle ou à débuter l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale sur fond de
manifestations des bonnets jaunes
mutualistes devant le Sénat il demande
l'annulation d'un amendement du
Gouvernement sur les clauses de
désignation des mutuelles qui créent
pour chaque entreprise d'une branche
professionnelle l'obligation de
travailler avec l'organisme de
complémentaires santé choisis par les
représentants de cette branche mais
avant de rentrer dans le détail de ce
texte écoutez la réaction de François
Rebsamen le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat il a réagi au hué et
aussi fait visant François Hollande lors
des cérémonies du 11 novembre on
l'écoute
l'indignation devant le comportement
anti républicain j'allais même dire
anti-franches anti-France que peut que
peuvent avoir ou qu'on peut avoir des
membres de partie d'extrême droite qui
était là
bafouant ce temps de recueillement et de
rassemblement
oubliant ceux qui sont morts pour la
France et donc c'est ce message
d'indignation que nous devons relayer
on retrouve tout de suite tam-train nuit
en duplex de la salle des conférences du
Sénat pour parler projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avec
votre invité thème aujourd'hui le
sénateur UMP du Vaucluse alain Milon oui
bonjour Delphine effectivement je me
trouve avec Alain Milon sénateur UMP du
Vaucluse et vice-président de la
commission des affaires sociales bonjour
tout d'abord l'UMP ne votera pas le
budget de la Sécurité sociale pour 2014
tout simplement d'abord quels sont vos
principaux grillés nous ne voterons pas
le budget de la Sécurité sociale tel
qu'il est présenté une première partie
qui concerne les recettes une deuxième
partie qui concerne les dépenses en ce
qui concerne les recettes il y a un nom
d'âme prévu à 2,4 c'est à dire c'est le
montant prévisionnel établi tous les ans
sur les dépenses de l'assurance maladie
en fait c'est l'autorisation
d'augmentation des dépenses par rapport
à l'année précédente donc de 4 ça veut
dire que on autorise 4 milliards 100
millions de dépenses supplémentaires en
2014 par
direct on parle de la télémédecine de la
chirurgie ambulatoire ça c'est au niveau
des dépenses et c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelques quelques efforts qui sont faits
particuliers en particulier comme vous
le disiez sur la télémédecine où on
accentue la télémédecine sur l'ensemble
du territoire national et en particulier
dans les endroits où ils sont considérés
comme étant des arts médicaux et ça me
semble être ça nous semble être une
excellente chose comme le fait de
accentuer la chirurgien ambulatoire sur
l'ensemble du territoire c'est une
excellente chose ce qui nous semble
moins bon c'est par exemple les tarifs
dégressifs c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'il y
a un établissement marche bien et si ces
établissement cet établissement qui
marche bien dépasse un petit peu ses
prévisions mais tout ce qui est dépassé
par rapport aux prévisions et payer
moins cher que tout ce qui est en deçà
de prévisions et ça ne semble pas être
une bonne chose pour les établissements
qui marchent bien évidemment pour les
établissements qui ont des problèmes
qu'il y ait des aides qu'il y ait des
réflexions qui soient mises en place
nous sommes aussi d'accord vous le
disiez vous ne voterez donc pas les
recettes et a priori vous n'est pas les
seuls puisque les communistes ont déjà
dit quand l'État il ne voteraient pas le
budget de la Sécurité sociale pour 2014
vous et des prélèvements nouveaux qui
sont faits sur les familles est-ce que
sur le fond donc se rejetterait probable
du texte ne pose pas un problème quand
même vis-à-vis du Sénat qui a rejeté de
nombreux textes et ensuite et bien la
rédaction comment dire législative
revient finalement à l'Assemblée
nationale qui a le dernier mot
le fait que le Sénat refuse des textes
du gouvernement tel qu'ils nous sont
présentés tant approuvé que nous avons
une réflexion qui va suffisamment loin
pour essayer de proposer d'autres choses
qui ne sont pas acceptées par le
gouvernement ni par la majorité de
l'Assemblée nationale alors je pense que
au contraire le Sénat joue son rôle dans
la réflexion l'Assemblée nationale joue
son rôle dans le suivi du gouvernement
et peut-être que au bout du compte c'est
plutôt le suivi qui est mal vu par la
population que la réflexion merci à la
million d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup Tam pour cette interview
alors tout de suite sans plus tarder
direction l'hémicycles du Sénat ou a
débuté et bien à l'examen du projet de
budget pour à la sécurité sociale bonne
séance et on se retrouve tout à l'heure
monsieur le président
madame monsieur le ministre chers
collègues madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le rapporteur pour avis Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs au fond j'ai le
sentiment de ne pas vous quitter puisque
il y a quelques jours encore nous étions
rassemblés ici pour un autre débat celui
des retraites celui sur les retraites
débat qui n'est pas totalement sans lien
évidemment avec ce que nous abordons
aujourd'hui comme discussion
depuis un an puisque nous allons
débattre de l'avenir de notre protection
sociale et du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale je
veux indiquer le choix de ce
gouvernement de maintenir un haut niveau
de protection sociale pour nos
concitoyens ce choix il est affirmé de
manière résolue y compris dans la
situation économique et financière
difficile que nous connaissons même si
cela ne veut pas dire que des réformes
de fonds ne sont pas nécessaires et ces
réformes de fonds ce sont celles que le
gouvernement engage mais à un moment où
l'on entend des voix s'élevées qui au
fond en appel à la remise en question de
notre modèle social lui-même il paraît
important de redire avec force à cette
tribune que le gouvernement dans la
période actuelle a fait ou affirmer la
volonté que les droits sociaux devaient
être maintenu et renforcée parce que
renoncer à notre modèle social cela
voudrait dire renvoyer chacune et chacun
a sa responsabilité individuelle cela
voudrait dire au fond permettre à ceux
qui ont les moyens de s'assurer
individuellement de le faire et
d'abandonner les autres ce choix-là le
gouvernement ne le fait pas ne s'y
résout pas et ne le fera pas c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons dès
notre arrivée aux responsabilités pris
des mesures importantes nous permettant
de rétablir de redresser les comptes
sociaux car le redressement des comptes
sociaux est évidemment une condition
nécessaire pour le maintien d'une
politique sociale forte ou deux
politiques sociales fortes des l'été
2012 nous avons engagé ce travail qui
nous a permis de faire baisser
progressivement le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale de 21 milliards d'euros
déficit que nous avons trouvé en
arrivant aux responsabilités à 16
milliards pour l'année 2013 avec un
objectif affirmé pour 2014 de ramener ce
déficit en dessous des 13 milliards 12
milliards 800 millions d'euros ces
résultats nous les obtenons donc dans le
cadre d'une maîtrise et dépenses
affirmée assumer qui s'est traduit
encore pour l'année 2013 par des
dépenses d'assurance maladie
inférieure aux objectifs qui avaient été
chiffrées et ce malgré un contexte
sanitaire difficile puisque vous le
savez nous avons connu une pandémie
grippale parmi les plus rudes des
dernières années qui donc a représenter
un surcoût important pour les finances
publiques politiques d'assurance maladie
qui donc est maîtrisée et qui pour
autant ne s'accompagne d'aucun des
remboursements c'est l'un des choix que
nous faisons et c'est dans le même
esprit maîtrise des comptes affirmation
de politique structurelle volonté de ne
pas faire porter aux assurés la
responsabilité ou la charge des
économies à engager que nous abordons ce
nouveau projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale en effet face aux
inquiétudes de nos concitoyens nous
voulons renforcer les piliers de la
protection sociale cela passe comme je
l'indiquais il y a un instant par la
mise en place de politique de fonds
politiques structurelle comme on dit
mais disons politiques de fond qui nous
servent à affirmer des priorités et à
afficher des objectifs auxquels nous
devons nous tenir à l'évidence la loi
sur les retraites trouve sa traduction
dans les comptes sociaux nous n'allons
pas l'aborder ici je ne reviens pas sur
les grandes orientations de cette loi le
débat est encore frais à nos esprits je
ne doute pas que l'Assemblée nationale
nous permettra d'avancer sur la voie de
l'adoption de cette réforme décisive
pour l'avenir de nos régimes de retraite
et la justice de nos régimes de retraite
dans les années à venir mais évidemment
nous trouvons dans les comptes sociaux
la traduction concrète des choix qui
sont faits par le Gouvernement en la
matière projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale qui concrétise aussi
nous orientations et notre action en
direction des familles Dominique
Bertinotti aura l'occasion dans un
instant d'y revenir mais il s'agit pour
nous de manière tout à fait assumée et
affirmée d'adapter notre politique
familiale aux évolutions de la société
c'est ainsi que nous proposons la
modulation de certaines de certaines
prestations mais que nous disons
clairement et fortement qu'une politique
familiale aujourd'hui ne peut pas se
limiter à l'appréciation du niveau des
prestations versées aux familles qu'une
politique familiale peut aussi de qu'on
doit enfin réside aussi dans la
possibilité de donner aux familles de
mieux concilier leur vie professionnelle
et leur vie familiale c'est ainsi que
d'ici 2017 275
000 places d'accueil pour les enfants de
moins de 3 ans seront créés et cela
représente un engagement fort et un
choix structurant pour nos politiques
dans le cadre de ce projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale nous
marquons aussi un soutien net en faveur
des personnes âgées et handicapées
Michel Delaunay puis Marie Arlette
Carlotti auront l'occasion d'y revenir à
leur tour l'ONDA médico-social va
évoluer de 3% ce qui pour les personnes
âgées représentent par exemple 130
millions de crédits supplémentaires pour
la médicalisation des EHPAD de la même
façon nous marquons clairement notre
engagement pour va permettre la mise en
oeuvre du plan Alzheimer et ce plan
poursuit son chemin si j'ose dire et ça
déclinaison avec Michel Delaunay nous
aurons l'occasion dans les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois de présenter
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
pour adapter notre société au
vieillissement de la population qui
marque l'engagement fort de ce
gouvernement pour permettre que les
personnes
âgées les personnes perdant
progressivement leur autonomie soit à la
fois mieux accompagnés mieux intégrer et
surtout que nous puissions retarder le
plus possible ce moment les premières
mesures de cette loi seront applicables
dès le 1er janvier 2015 mais sans
attendre 100 millions d'euros
issus de la Casa permettront dès 2014 de
soutenir la politique en faveur des
personnes âgées je sais que que cette
évolution et cet engagement de la part
du gouvernement ont été suivis avec
attention par la commission des affaires
sociales et à n'en pas douter par
l'ensemble de cette assemblée pour
suivre l'effort sur le médico-social en
matière de médico-social c'est aussi je
le disais renforcer le soutien aux
personnes en situation de handicap et le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale nous permettra de
financer la première annuité du plan
autisme et de consacrer plus de 150
millions d'euros à la création de place
dans les établissements et les services
pour personnes handicapées enfin mais
évidemment c'est un élément tout à fait
décisif cette loi se projette de loi
constitue la première étape de la mise
en oeuvre de la stratégie nationale de
santé dont je veux rappeler que le
premier objectif est la réduction des
inégalités en matière faire de santé et
c'est donc dans cette dans ce cadre-là
et pour atteindre ses objectifs là que
nous avons construit l'ONDAM pour 2014
cet objectif national de dépenses des
assurances maladie progressera en 2014
de 2,4 % ce qui représente un effort
exigeant pour la politique que nous
menons plus de 2 milliards quatre
d'économies seront ainsi réalisés
auxquels s'ajoutera l'impact des
dépenses non réalisées en 2013 tous les
secteurs de l'offre de santé sans
exception
participeront à la maîtrise de la
dépense mais comme l'an dernier aucun
des remboursements aucune franchise
nouvelle aucun transfert vers les
organismes complémentaires
n'interviendront c'est une volonté de
notre part une priorité que nous
assumons et que nous affichons
l'assurance maladie je veux le dire ici
avec force doit rester le pilier
fondamental de la prise en charge des
dépenses de santé depuis 2004 nous
assistons à un effritement de cette
prise en charge au profit des organismes
complémentaires j'ai donc pris
l'engagement d'enrayer cette tendance et
un bilan annuel sera remis au Parlement
sur la part des dépenses prises en
charge par l'assurance maladie et ce dès
l'année prochaine mais dès maintenant
nous posons les premiers jalons de la
stratégie nationale de santé ce texte
doit d'abord permettre de prolonger
d'amplifier le combat pour l'accès aux
soins et l'égalité de l'accès aux soins
il est nécessaire de ce point de vue de
franchir une nouvelle étape dans la
généralisation de la complémentaire
santé
la priorité est d'abord de simplifier
les procédures pour lutter contre le non
recours de ce qui peuvent bénéficier de
l'ACS l'aide à la complémentaire santé
par ailleurs l'accès à la CMU sera
facilité pour les étudiants en situation
de précarité ou en situation d'isolement
et d'isolement familial c'est ainsi que
ce texte prévoit le renouvellement
automatique du droit à l'ACS pour les
bénéficiaires de la SPA permet d'ouvrir
plus facilement le l'accès à la CMU pour
certains étudiants et envisa et permet
de mettre en place des appels d'offres
pour les acs pour la CS qui permettra
dès l'année prochaine de déterminer des
contrats vers lesquels seront orientés
les personnes éligibles à la CS ce qui
doit permettre de lutter contre le non
recours à ce droit qui existe dans notre
pays c'est une avancée importante et
cohérente je veux le souligner avec les
propositions formulées par Madame
Archambault dans le rapport qu'elle a
remis au gouvernement et que je salue
ici
ce texte ouvre un autre grand chantier
celui de l'amélioration des contrats qui
sont proposés à nos concitoyens c'est
ainsi que nous voulons permettre de
favoriser le recours à des contrats
d'irresponsables et solidaires en
permettant de mieux identifier les
critères selon lesquels seront
labellisés comme responsables et
solidaire des contrats l'Assemblée
nationale a souhaité soutenir cette
démarche en différenciant de façon plus
forte la taxation qui s'applique au
contrat responsable et à ceux qui ne le
sont pas et je crois qu'il s'agit là
d'une initiative positive par ailleurs
nous avons attiré les conséquences de la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel en
matière de protection complémentaire
collective de branches les branches
pourront donc recommander des organismes
dans le cadre de contrat offrant un haut
niveau de solidarité qui feront l'objet
d'incitation par le biais de la
différenciation du forfait social enfin
ce projet de loi prévoit des avancées
importantes en matière d'accès à
l'optique pour l'ensemble des
bénéficiaires de l'aide à la
complémentaire santé la prochaine étape
pour lever les barrières financières qui
entravent l'accès aux soins relèvent une
ambition plus grande il s'agit de la
généralisation du tiers payant pour
l'ensemble des soins de ville avant 2017
et dès 2014 pour les bénéficiaires de
l'aide à la complémentaire santé je ne
doute pas que nous aurons l'occasion
d'aborder cette question dans nos débats
avec ce texte au-delà de l'accès de la
réduction des inégalités de santé nous
engageons la refondation de l'autre de
notre organisation de soins et c'est la
deuxième priorité ou le deuxième pilier
de la stratégie nationale de santé ce
que j'ai appelé la révolution du premier
recours pour reprendre la formulation
des Canadiens qui parlaient de virage
ambulatoire cette révolution donc du
premier recours en sera la pierre
angulaire nous prolongerons d'une année
les expérimentations des nouveaux modes
de rémunération tout en étendant ce
dispositif à 150 nouvelles équipes les
centres de santé ont suscité beaucoup de
débats tentent à l'assemblée que lors
des débats de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat ces centres seront
pleinement concernés par le
développement des nouveaux modes de
rémunération en parallèle ce texte
propose d'initier la réforme du
financement des en prenant mieux en
compte la situation des établissements
isolés par ailleurs la dégraissie une
dégressivité tarifaire sera mise en
place de manière ponctuelle pour réguler
les effets parfois inflationnistes de la
tarification à l'activité enfin nous
expérimenterons le financement au
parcours dans les établissements
hospitaliers en nous appuyant sur de
nouveaux financement pour la prise en
charge de l'insuffisance rénale
chronique et la radiothérapie du cancer
pour parvenir à un pilotage financier
plus adapté aux réalités de terrain les
agences régionales de santé seront
autorisées à procéder à des transferts
entre enveloppes ce qu'on appelle la
fongibilité mais qui n'est
compréhensible que de ceux qui
travaillent au quotidien sur ces
questions et donc les agences régionales
de santé seront autorisées à au fond
faire bouger leurs en financière dans le
cadre fixé par le Parlement la stratégie
nationale de santé investit aussi
largement le champ de la santé publique
et c'est ainsi que dans le cadre de ce
projet de loi deux objectifs majeurs
sont fixés la lutte contre le tabac et
l'accès à la contraception pour ce qui
est de la lutte contre le tabagisme il
n'y a aucun doute que c'est la situation
des jeunes fumeurs qui est la plus
préoccupante je propose donc de mettre
en place une aide au sevrage tabagique
pour les jeunes adultes avec une prise
en charge renforcée des substituts
nicotiniques prise en charge renforcée
ça veut dire très concrètement le
triplement de cette prise en charge par
ailleurs pour ce qui est de l'accès à la
contraception il s'agit de prolonger des
mesures prises l'année dernière qui
avait permis d'améliorer l'accès à la
contraception des jeunes femmes et en
particulier des mine je propose de
poursuivre dans cette voie en instaurant
le tiers payant pour les actes associés
à la prescription de contraception pour
les mineurs enfin ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale vise
à renforcer l'efficience de notre
politique du médicament une politique du
médicament efficace n'est pas la course
en avant c'est soutenir le bon usage des
produits de santé d'abord en luttant
contre leur surconsommation et ensuite
en permettant leur bonne utilisation
c'est pourquoi je souhaite que nous
expérimentions la dispensation à l'unité
par les pharmacies d'officines par
exemple en commençant par certains
antibiotiques ensuite la mise en place
d'un répertoire des médicaments bio
similaires doit permettre le
développement du recours à ces
médicaments dans un cadre sécurisé qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui enfin une
politique du médicament efficace mais
nous avions eu l'occasion il n'y a pas
si longtemps lors du débat organisé par
Monsieur barbier et son groupe c'est une
politique qui favorise c'est aussi une
politique qui favorise la diffusion de
l'innovation or nous constatons que
certaines procédures sont trop longues
il convient donc de réduire lors des
lait pour permettre une prise de
décision rapide dans un contexte
sécurisé c'est le sens des engagements
que le gouvernement a pris dans le cadre
du conseil stratégique des industries de
santé et qui trouve une traduction
concrète dans ce texte mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs avec ce projet
nous nous maintenant le cap fixé depuis
le début du quinquennat celui du
redressement de nos comptes et d'une
transformation en profondeur de notre
modèle social cette constance dans nos
choix est aussi une condition pour
rétablir la confiance des Français dans
le pacte social et retrouver le sens du
progrès je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Bernard Cazeneuve mini chargé
du budget
c'est le président mesdames les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais en quelques mots
compléter ce que vient de dire Madame la
Ministre concernant le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
essayant de mettre l'accent sur quelques
aspects budgétaires et fiscaux qui sont
complémentaires des questions qui
viennent d'être évoquées à l'instant et
qui me permettront d'apporter toute
information
utile à votre assemblée concernant le
contenu de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale le
premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur la trajectoire de
redressement de nos comptes publics dans
laquelle nous sommes engagés depuis plus
de 18 mois désormais qui nous engage non
seulement devant le pays qui nous engage
également devant les institutions de
l'Union européenne puisque au titre de
programme du programme de stabilité nous
devons remplir nos objectifs de
redressement des comptes publics
qui nous engage aussi dans la
préservation de nos services publics
dans leur montée en gamme dans la
consolidation du modèle social français
car si nous ne parvenons pas à faire en
sorte que sur chaque sujet la bonne
dépense publique ne chasse pas la
mauvaise nous serons en difficulté pour
maintenir la qualité de notre système de
protection sociale de nos services
publics qui constituent le patrimoine de
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et par
conséquent il nous faut préserver ce
patrimoine avec beaucoup d'attention et
de vigilance
se redressement des comptes publics
commence à donner des résultats
il m'arrive d'entendre que le fait que
un décalage existe entre les objectifs
de déficit nominaux que nous nous sommes
assignés à nous-mêmes et ceux qui sont
constatés en fin d'année que ce décalage
puisse exister signifie que les déficits
non il diminue et je voudrais d'ailleurs
donner pour être extrêmement précis la
séquence des déficits constatés depuis
2012 pour bien montrer que cette
trajectoire est tenue que les objectifs
que nous étions à signer sont bien là
même si pour des raisons qui tiennent à
l'absence de croissance nous allons
moins vite dans le redressement de nos
comptes que nous aurions pu le souhaiter
pour ce qui concerne le déficit nominal
il était de 5,3% du PIB en 2011 lorsque
nous sommes arrivés en situation de
responsabilité il était en 2012 après
que des mesures ont été prises en loi de
finance
rectificative de
4,8%, il aurait dû être de 4,5% mais
nous avons dû absorber en 2012 en fin de
gestion notamment le déficit ou la dette
de Dexia pour des raisons qui tiennent
aux difficultés auxquels cette banque a
été confronté également contribuer au
rétablissement du budget de l'Union
européenne puisqu'en novembre 2010 une
décision avait été prise par le
précédent gouvernement liaison avec
d'autres gouvernements de l'Union
européenne contingentant les crédits de
paiement alloués à l'Union européenne
pour lui permettre d'atteindre ces
objectifs budgétaires voilà là les deux
principales raisons qui expliquent le
décalage entre 4,8 et 4 5 de déficit
vous constatez que la plus grande partie
de ce décalage est imputable à des
décisions prises antérieurement à
l'arrivée de ce gouvernement et que nous
avons dû éponger en prenant des
dispositions en lot-finance
rectificative qui représentait des
montants significatifs en
2013 nous serons à 4,1% de déficits
nominal et en 2014 nous serons à 3,6%
nous serons donc passés en quelques
années
de
5,3,6 là où la moyenne de déficit
nominal du précédent quinquennat était
supérieur à 5%
donc le déficit nominal diminue les
efforts auxquels les Français sont
appelés comment s'apporter leurs fruits
et ce qui concerne les contes sociaux
n'échappent pas à cette tendance je
voudrais après que la ministre l'a fait
elle-même rappeler la séquence des
chiffres lorsque nous sommes arrivés en
2012 le précédent déficit des comptes
sociaux était de près de 21 milliards
20,8 milliards très exactement si nous
n'avions pas pris de disposition en 2012
nous aurions été sur un déficit des
comptes sociaux supérieurs à 21
milliards en réalité il est de 17,5
milliards en 2012 en 2013 le déficit
sera de
16,2 milliards et si nous tenons nos
objectifs en 2014 le budget que nous
présentons permettra d'afficher un
déficit de régime général et du Fonds de
solidarité vieillesse de 12,8 milliards
ce qui signifie que dans l'espace de 18
mois par les efforts que nous aurons
accomplis la volonté de maîtrise des
comptes publics et des comptes sociaux
dont nous aurons témoignés nous aurons
diminué le déficit du régime général et
du fond de solidarité vieillesse de 8
milliards et à la fin du quinquennat si
cette tendance se maintient le déficit
sera de 4 milliards ce qui signifie que
nous aurons en l'espace de 4 ans et demi
divisé par 5 le déficit des comptes
sociaux je rappelle ces chiffres parce
que il arrive que dans
l'espace public le vacarme ou le taux
Hugo immédiatique aidant on est le
sentiment que les difficultés de
l'économie empêche la maîtrise des
comptes sociaux il n'en est rien aussi
bien pour ceux qui concerne les déficits
nominaux que pour ceux qui concerne
l'évolution des déficits du régime
général et du fond de solidarité
vieillesse cette maîtrise des comptes
n'est pas le but de notre stratégie
comme cela a été rappelé à l'instant par
Marisol Touraine c'est le moyen si nous
voulons maîtriser les comptes sociaux et
si nous nous attachons au respect de
cette trajectoire de finance publique
c'est parce que nous savons que si nous
ne faisons pas cela c'est le modèle
social français dans ses équilibres dans
son identité dans sa structure qui se
trouvera remise en cause et si nous
voulons assurer la pérennité de ce
modèle nous devons prendre ces
dispositions en gestion je veux
d'ailleurs faire écho à un certain
nombre de documents de la Cour des
comptes dont vous évoquez le contenu
très souvent dans les commissions du
Sénat mais également de l'Assemblée
nationale la Cour des comptes prévoyait
une évolution des
déficits de lactave et du Fonds de
solidarité vieillesse pour la période de
2011-2018 à hauteur de 70 milliards et
pour la branche maladie la branche
famille de 72 milliards en réalité le
total du déficit de ces deux branches
contenu de l'effort de maîtrise que nous
faisons sera de 82 milliards là où il
aurait dû être de 142 milliards ce qui
veut dire que nous épargnerons une
dégradation de l'ordre de 60 milliards
des comptes et par conséquent de la
dette des comptes sociaux ce qu'il a
encore est une manière de bien mesurer
l'effort que nous faisons pour faire en
sorte que le budget des comptes sociaux
soit rigoureusement tenu et la dépense
maîtrisée je voudrais insister également
et ce sera le dernier point sur les
aspects budgétaires et comptable sur le
fait que les efforts que nous faisons de
maîtrise des déficits notamment de la
branche vieillesse nous permettront
compte tenu du dispositif de reprise de
la dette par la CADES décider en 2010
avec son niveau annuel de 10 milliards
plafonnés à 62 milliards de reprendre
une partie de la dette
de la famille et de la maladie pour
2014 à hauteur de 4 milliards d'euros ce
qui permettra sans une mesure générale
de prélèvement
de parvenir à
contenir la dette des comptes sociaux
par cette reprise de dette à hauteur de
4 milliards voilà pour le premier point
concernant l'évolution des déficits la
maîtrise de la dépense et la maîtrise
des comptes le deuxième point sur lequel
je voudrais dire quelques mots c'est sur
le fait que les mesures de prélèvement
qui sont inscrites dans le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014 sont des mesures de
prélèvement qui sont destinées d'une
part à assurer le rééquilibrage de
compte qui nous ont été laissés dans des
situations de déficit préoccupants soit
de financer de nouvelles orientations
politiques qui correspondent à un
objectif de justice et je voudrais
prendre les exemples précis prélèvement
décidé essayer de vous indiquer les
raisons pour lesquelles ces décisions
ont été prises pour ce qui concerne tout
d'abord les retraites l'augmentation de
la cotisation et la fiscalisation des
majorations de pension permettront leur
équilibrage de notre régime de retraite
qui la garantie de sa pérennité nous
avons également la volonté c'est ce dont
témoignent l'article 9 et l'article 10
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale de faire en sorte que
nous puissions pour le régime des
indépendants mais aussi pour le régime
agricole à travers la mise
en sommeil d'un certain nombre de
pratiques d'optimisation dans les
exploitations agricoles de financer les
engagements qui avaient été pris
concernant la réforme des retraites
agricoles avec un objectif là aussi de
solidarité et de justice pour ce qui
concerne les mesures prises au titre de
la branche famille c'est-à-dire les
mesures concernant le quotient familial
qui doit permettre de dégager un
milliard ressources qui sont financées
essentiellement par 13% des familles
dont la française dans la capacité
contributive et la plus importante ces
mesures de quotient permettront de
diminuer le déficit de la branche
famille qui lorsque nous sommes arrivés
étaient à hauteur de 2,5 milliards
d'euros mais également de financer des
politiques nouvelles
avec le concours d'économie puisque il y
a 200 millions d'économies dans le
budget 2014 qui sont appelés à monter en
puissance jusqu'à atteindre 800 millions
à l'horizon 2017 ces mesures de quotient
et ces mesures d'économie permettront de
financer des 270
000 places d'accueil pour les jeunes
enfants de financer l'augmentation du
complément familial et de la société de
l'allocation de soutien familial dans le
cas du plan pauvreté pour les familles
les plus en difficulté
la fiscalisation de la contribution des
entreprises
au contrat collectif de complémentaires
santé s'inscrit dans la volonté du
gouvernement au titre ou au terme de la
grande nationale interprofessionnelle de
généraliser ces
dispositifs collectifs de
complémentaires santé c'est donc une
mesure de justice que nous avons prise
en généralisant ces complémentaires
santé de la même manière que nous avons
voulu augmenter le plafond de la CMU de
manière à pouvoir permettre à 750 000
familles d'avoir accès à ce service
auquel elle n'avait pas accès jusqu'à
présent enfin je voudrais dire un mot
d'une mesure qui a fait débat au cours
des dernières semaines et que l'on
comprendrait pas que je passe sous
silence que la mesure de simplification
et d'harmonisation proposée par le
gouvernement concernant les prélèvements
sociaux sur les produits d'épargne
et cette mesure
contrairement à ce qui a peut être dit
parfois sans que la rigueur n'est été
toujours convoquée n'est pas une taxe
nouvelle les prélèvements sociaux sur
les produits d'épargne sont déjà 15,5 %
il y a donc pas eu de décision de mettre
en place un prélèvement sociaux sur les
produits d'épargne qui jusqu'à présent
n'auraient pas existé une grande partie
des produits d'épargne était déjà
fiscalisés à la sortie au taux de
prélèvement sociaux de cases
5%, il s'agit notamment des PEL
concluent à partir de 2011 ou ayant une
durée de vie de plus de 10 ans il s'agit
également des produits d'assurance vie
pour les versements intervenus après
1997 ce qui existait était un dispositif
confus ou des produits de même nature
étaient taxés au prélèvement sociaux à
des taux différents pour des raisons qui
tenaient à la superposition de
dispositif hérité de l'histoire donc il
est faux de dire que une taxe nouvelle
de 15,5% a été décidé par ce
gouvernement applicable aux produits
d'épargne au moment de leur sortie le
taux de prélèvement sociaux sur les
produits d'épargne comme sur d'autres
plus-values étaient déjà 15,5%, il n'a
pas été décidé de créer ce prélèvement
il a été décidé par souci
d'harmonisation de l'appliquer à
l'ensemble des produits d'épargne
identiques deuxième point
il n'a pas non plus été décidé
d'augmenter ce taux
ce taux a été augmenté par nos
prédécesseurs de façon très
significative
dans le tumulte des débats
parlementaires à l'Assemblée nationale
du retentissement médiatique qui en a
été donné
on a oublié de préciser que le taux des
prélèvements sociaux sur les produits
d'épargne était passé de 10 à 15,5%
entre 2009 et 2012
ce qui représente un prélèvement sur les
épargnants quelle que soit le niveau de
leur épargne de 6 milliards en trois ans
6 milliards en trois ans le taux de
prélèvement sur l'épargne est passé de
10 à 15,5 et nous n'avons pas proposé
d'augmenter ce taux nous avons
simplement proposé que tous les produits
de même catégorie se voient appliquer le
même dispositif de prélèvement au type
des prélèvements sociaux à la sortie
cela a suscité des interrogations et
nous avons par conséquent décider parce
que nous sommes soucieux de faire en
sorte que nous puissions sur tous les
sujets
ou des apaisants sont possibles ou des
concertations sont souhaitables de les
initier nous avons donc décidé de sortir
de la mesure
tous les produits d'épargne à
l'exception de l'assurance vie et si
nous avons gardé l'assurance vie c'est
pour des raisons qui tiennent à la
spécificité de ce produit mais aussi et
surtout au fait que nous avons
l'intention à la faveur du PLFSS et du
projet de loi de finance rectificative
de présenter un dispositif global de
réforme de l'assurance vie qui est
destinée à faire en sorte que une grande
partie des avoir déposées en assurance
vie une partie des avoir déposés en
assurance vie pardon puisse être orienté
vers le financement du logement et vers
le financement des entreprises nous
souhaitons le faire dans l'intérêt du
monde de l'entreprise de la politique du
logement nous souhaitons le faire aussi
en accord avec le monde de
l'assurance avec lequel nous avons été
amenés à nous concerter de telle sorte
parce que cette réforme puisse donner
tous ses effets et permettre
la relance de l'activité économique et
de la croissance enfin le dernier point
sur lequel je voudrais assister avant de
conclure c'est sur l'importance des
économies en dépense qui sont inscrites
dans ce projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale il s'agit là d'un
effort de 4,5 milliards d'euros cet
effort se répartit de la manière
suivante d'abord sur l'ONDAM ou nous
avons constaté depuis notre arrivée en
responsabilité que les efforts que nous
faisons pour maîtriser la dépense porte
leurs fruits puisque en 2012 les
dépenses de l'ondamment ont été
réalisées un milliard au-dessus de
l'objectif que la précédente majorité
s'était assignée à elle-même et nous
avons constaté avec Marisol Touraine à
l'occasion de la dernière commission des
comptes sociaux que pour 2013 nous
étions au moins à 600 millions autour de
l'objectif grâce aux efforts qu'ils ont
fait de maîtrise de la dépense de
d'Assurance Maladie cela nous permettra
de maintenir la progression de l'ONDAM à
2,4% là au cours des 10 dernières années
elle avait été en moyenne de 4%, ce qui
permettra de dégager sur les dépenses
maladies sans remettre en cause ni des
remboursements ni la qualité des
prestations à peu près 3 milliards pour
l'année 2014 nous avons 800 millions
d'économies résultant du différé de la
l'indexation des retraites au mois
d'octobre nous avons 500 millions
d'économies qui résulte de la
modernisation des caisses de sécurité
sociale et notamment des efforts de
dématérialisation et de numérisation qui
permettent de constater des économies
significatives et cet effort d'économie
en dépense nous entendons le poursuivre
parce qu'il est l'une des manières de
faire en sorte encore une fois que la
mauvaise démontre public ne chasse pas
la bonne et que les prélèvements ne
soient pas prélèvement obligatoire ne
soit pas davantage sollicité au cours
des prochaines années pour équilibrer
nos comptes voilà ce que je voulais dire
sur ce projet de loi de financement de
sécurité sociale pour 2014 je forme le
vœu que dans cette assemblée ou ces
questions sont regardées de très près
avec beaucoup de compétences et de
méticulosité par chacune et chacun
d'entre vous nous puissions avoir un
débat riche qui permettent à aller au
bout des interrogations de conforter les
politiques publiques de renforcer nos
politiques de solidarité pour faire en
sorte que le modèle social français
monte en gamme et se trouve dans les
années qui viennent renforcer
monsieur le Président
Madame les ministres monsieur le
ministre
ma présidente de la commission mes chers
collègues
l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale nous
donne aujourd'hui l'occasion de dresser
un premier bilan de l'action menée par
la nouvelle majorité en matière de
finances sociales
18 mois ce sont en effet écoulé depuis
l'élection présidentielle et la
nomination d'un nouveau gouvernement
18 mois qui nous ont permis de définir
dans le dialogue et la concertation les
contours des réformes structurelles
nécessaires ou redressement de nos
comptes publics 18 mois qui nous ont
permis de rompre avec 5 ans de dérive en
proposant aux Français une gestion
responsable de nos comptes sociaux
quelle situation avons vous en effet
trouver en mai 2012
des déficits de 22,5 milliards d'euros
pour le FSV et l'ensemble des régimes de
base obligatoires et de 17,4 milliards
pour le régime général c'est la vérité
à nouveau des rapages difficiles annoncé
par la Commission des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale au titre de la première
moitié de l'année 2012 une dégradation
des comptes qui sans atteindre les
records établis en 2010 apparaissait
suffisamment prononcé pour remettre en
question l'existence même notre système
de protection sociale
certes je l'ai rappelé dans notre
dernière réunion de commission
l'équilibre comptable ne doit pas
constituer une fin en soi en période de
crise notre système de protection
sociale de bien évidemment jouer son
rôle d'amortisseur mais comment
pourrait-il le faire lorsque son niveau
de déficit est tel que la soutenabilité
des politiques qui est censé mettre en
oeuvre peut-être remise en cause comment
pourrait-il le faire lorsque ce fameux
trou de la Sécu se croise au point de
faire douter nos compatriotes de la
crédibilité des droits qu'elle est
censée leur garantir tel est le constat
qui a conduit le gouvernement à placer
le redressement de nos comptes sociaux
en tête de ces priorités au regard de ce
lourd passif
hérité de la gestion précédente dans
quelle situation sommes-nous un an et
demi plus tard nous ne sommes pas encore
sortis jaune rouge loin sans faut mais
la tendance affichée nous permet
d'espérer un retour vers des soldes plus
conformes au principe d'une bonne
gestion des ressources publiques d'une
part les efforts réalisés pour inverser
la tendance de 2012 on portait leurs
fruits la suppression des niches
fiscales et le relèvement des taxes sur
le capital voter dans le cas de la loi
de finances rectificative du 16 août
2012 ont permis de respecter les
prévisions fixées en loi de financement
par le précédent gouvernement
d'autre part les mesures prises dans le
cas du PLFSS pour 2013 nous permettent
d'afficher pour l'année en cours une
nouvelle réduction des déficits sociaux
en dépit d'un contexte économique
dégradé notre collègue à l'amidon nous
reprocher mercredi vous consiste à
reproche d'ailleurs mercredi dernier de
déployer beaucoup d'efforts pour
convaincre les membres de la commission
des de faire social des progrès
accomplis en matière de déficit pourtant
les résultats sont là en deux ans le
déficit des régimes obligatoires a été
réduit de 5,5 milliards d'euros le
déficit du régime général a diminué de
3,9 milliards d'euros les efforts
demandés à nos compatriotes n'ont donc
pas été 20 l'ajustement est sans doute
douloureux mais il permet d'endiguer la
dérive des comptes face à la crise peut
provoquer certes des mécontentement mais
il permet d'améliorer l'équité de notre
système de protection sociale cette
politique sera d'ailleurs poursuivi en
2014 plus de 8 milliards d'euros sont en
effet attendus des mesures inscrites
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale et le projet de loi
de finance afin de rapprocher les camps
du régime général de leur niveau d'avant
la crise
plus de 4 milliards d'économies seront
ainsi réalisés cela a été détaillé de
tellène à Monsieur le Ministre grâce à
la mise en oeuvre de la madame la
ministre également grâce à la mise en
œuvre de la réforme des retraites de la
réforme de la petite finale donc
mesdames les ministres et de la
stratégie nationale de santé nous
inscrivons donc dans une dynamique
positive entre nous par la montée en
puissance des réformes qui devrait
permettre à l'horizon 2017 de tendre
vers l'équilibre des comptes sociaux si
tel est le cas nous aurions en l'espace
d'une législature divisée le déficit de
la Sécurité sociale par plus de 4 et
nous aurions fait la preuve si besoin
était qu'une politique de gauche peut
faire rimer justice sociale et saine
gestion des comptes publics
s'agissant de la gestion de la dette
sociale j'avais regretté l'an dernier
l'absence dans le pffss de disposition
relative au transfert à la CADES des
déficits des branches famille et maladie
en effet en dépit de conditions de
marché tout à fait exceptionnelles il ne
me semblait pas de bonnes pratiques de
laisser Lacoste gérer en trésorerie les
déficits aussi élevés l'article 14 de ce
P bénéfss réussite à répondre à cette
préoccupation en proposant d'élargir le
dispositif de reprise de dette mise en
place par l'article 9 de la loi de
financement pour 2011 cet élargissement
qui ne modifie ni le montant maximal des
transferts ni la durée d'amortissement
de la dette sociale permettra de tirer
parti du rééquilibrage progressif des
comptes de la branche vieillesse
résultant des mesures adoptées dans le
cadre de la réforme des retraites il
permettra de reprendre près de 30
milliards d'euros entre 2013 et 2017 et
d'éviter d'avoir recourir à une mesure
globale synonyme d'augmentation du taux
de la serds ou d'affectation de
nouvelles ressources à la CADES
quels sont mes chers collègues les
principales considérations que je
souhaitais livrer au Sénat sur les
recettes et l'équilibre vous l'avez
compris nous respectons cette année
encore les engagements pris devant nos
concitoyens nous rendons à notre système
de protection sociale les marges de
manœuvre financières dont il a besoin
Nous garantissons au plus vulnérable les
moyens d'accéder au service qui leur
sont nécessaires la Commission a
d'ailleurs adoptée en ce sens un
amendement fixant le taux de la taxe
spéciale sur les contrats d'assurance à
3,5%
pour les contrats réservés aux
bénéficiaires de l'aide à l'acquisition
d'une complémentaire santé
ce taux réduit applicable contrat
sélectionné à l'issue de la procédure de
mise en concurrence prévue par l'article
45 de ce projet de loi devrait avoir un
double effet inciter les assureurs à
proposer des garanties de qualité à
moindre coût et encourager les
bénéficiaires de la CS à souscrire à ses
contrats diminuant ainsi le taux de non
recours à une complémentaire santé
j'espère mesdames et messieurs les
ministres que cette initiative recevra
votre assentiment j'en viens maintenant
à la partie du pffss relative à
l'assurance maladie le Premier ministre
a annoncé en février dernier la mise en
place d'une stratégie nationale de santé
que madame la ministre vous avez
détaillé le 23 septembre sans revenir
précisément sur ces différents points je
souhaite surtout saluer la méthode
cette stratégie embrasse dans son
ensemble notre système de santé et vise
à le transformer de matière globale
durable et pérenne pour l'adapter au
changement profonds que nous connaissons
tous n'est peut-être pas spectaculaire
dirons certains mais c'est la seule voie
efficace et pertinente
réorienter notre système vers la
prévention vers l'accompagnement global
des patients vers un décloisonnement des
prises en charge vers une meilleure
coopération entre les professionnels
vers une véritable collaboration entre
sanitaire social et médico-social donc
ré-orienter notre système ne peut se
faire en un jour au risque de casser
tout simplement les outils construits
pas à pas au fil des décennies la
concertation est une mise en œuvre
planifiée dans le temps sont les
conditions du caractère durable de
réforme d'ampleur c'est dans cet esprit
que s'inscrit le projet de loi de
financement pour 1000 pour 2014 qui
contient de nombreuses mesures que je
regrouperais en quatre axes mieux
organisé les soins primaires faciliter
l'accès aux soins et aux droits aménager
le financement des établissements de
santé améliorés le circuit du médicament
mieux organiser les soins primaires tout
d'abord il s'agit naturellement d'une
priorité pour notre système de santé
elle passe par le renforcement de la
prise en charge de proximité autour du
médecin traitant pour cela nous allons
prolonger d'une année l'expérimentation
relative ou nouveau mode de rémunération
mais je souhaite que les partenaires
conventionnels démarre au plus tôt les
négociations pour proposer un dispositif
pérenne de financement des équipes de
soins et de coordination il est
essentiel de définir clairement des
rémunérations qui soient complémentaires
ou paiement de l'acte au paiement à
l'acte c'est rémunérations différentes
constitue l'un des éléments dans la mise
en place de parcours de santé à cet
égard le PLFSS ouvre la voie à deux
expérimentations l'une sur
l'insuffisance rénale chronique l'autre
sur le traitement du cancer par
radiothérapie externe celles sur l'IRC
me semble particulièrement prometteuse
car la prise en charge de cette
pathologie repose nécessairement sur un
ensemble varié d'acteurs l'étude
d'impact précise d'ailleurs que le
promoteur du projet pourrait être chargé
de la répartition des crédits entre les
différents partenaires c'est une
évolution très intéressante et
particulièrement innovante en termes de
décloisement peut-être madame le
ministre pourrait nous nous apporter
quelques précisions sur ce point par
ailleurs le projet de loi mais
finalement en place les premiers pas
d'un cadre financier pour la
télémédecine ce qui me semble également
extrêmement important pour nos
territoires madame la ministre
l'Assemblée nationale a inséré une
disposition pour conforter les centres
de santé dont la fragilité financière a
été reconnue par le récent rapport de
ligase qui met en avant dans le même
temps leur grande utilité sociale et
sanitaire notre commission a souhaité
aller plus loin sur ce sujet pour
simplifier la gestion des centres et
renforcer encore leur place dans le
système de santé pouvez-vous nous
indiquer plus généralement quelles sont
les intentions du Gouvernement pour
mieux assurer la place des centres de
santé dans notre système de prise en
charge
faciliter l'accès aux soins et aux
droits constitue à mon sens le deuxième
axe de ce bel FSS parmi les différentes
mesures je n'évoquerai que celle
relative à la couverture complémentaire
en santé elles sont structurelles elles
visent à aider les bénéficiaires de la
CS à choisir un contrat dont le rapport
qualité-prix aura été validé par les
pouvoirs publics et surtout à mettre un
frein à la surenchère que nous avons
constaté dans le remboursement de
certains frais on ne rend service ni aux
Français ni au système de soins lui-même
en solvabilisant de manière excessive
certaines dépenses en prévoyant que les
contrats complémentaires pour bénéficier
d'un taux réduit de TSCA ne devront pas
prendre en charge des honoraires et des
frais au-delà d'un certain seuil tout en
nous obligeant rembourser le ticket
modérateur nous contribuons positivement
à la régulation des dépenses qui restent
à la charge de nos concitoyens et je ne
peux que m'en féliciter
par ailleurs notre commission a souhaité
aller plus loin que ce qu'avait proposé
l'Assemblée nationale pour faciliter
l'accès à la CMUC et à la CS on nous
inspirant du dispositif qui lie le RSA
socle à la CMUC nous avons prévu que les
allocataires d'un minimum vieillesse ou
de l'AAH sont réputés satisfaire les
conditions pour bénéficier de la CS
cette mesure de simplification tant pour
les demandeurs que pour les personnels
des caisses me semblent lever un verrou
important alors même que l'ACS connaît
un taux de non recours très élevé madame
la ministre entendez-vous reprendre
cette mesure et quelles sont plus
généralement vous intentions pour lutter
contre le véritable parcours du
combattant que connaissent les plus
démunis dans l'accès à leurs droits
le troisième thème que je souhaite
aborder concerne le financement des
établissements de santé je serai brave
sur ce point car je ne peux que me
féliciter de la reprise de deux mesures
que nous avions proposées dans le
rapport de la Mecque de l'année dernière
avec les éminents reporters par
rapporteur pardon que sont qui a été
Jacky le Maine et notre collègue Milan
nous avions mis en avant le fait que les
principes même de la tarification à
l'activité pouvait mettre en difficulté
certains établissements isolés dont les
coûts fixes ne permettent pas de
s'aligner sur les coûts moyens calculer
nationalement pour l'élaboration des
tarifs nous avions aussi mis en avant le
risque inflationniste de la T2A
c'est pourquoi la minoration des tarifs
au-delà d'un certain seuil d'activité
peut constituer un outil permettant aux
finances publiques de bénéficier d'une
part des économies d'échelle que
certaines prestations génèrent pour
autant la communauté hospitalière montre
des signes d'inquiétude quant aux
modalités d'application de la mesure
proposée dans le PLFSS pouvez-vous
madame la ministre nous apporter des
précisions sur les activités qui seront
concernées par la dégressivité des
tarifs
quatrième axe de travail améliorer le
circuit du médicament là aussi le plvss
contient plusieurs mesures que je ne
détaillerai pas refonte des taxes
pharmaceutiques prises en charge des
patients traités avec un médicament
ayant bénéficier d'une autorisation
temporaire d'utilisation
expérimentation de la délivrance à
l'unité diffusion des bio similaires je
souhaite insister sur la proposition de
l'Assemblée nationale d'augmenter le
montant des remises sur les génériques
au-delà des actuels
17%. certes la situation des guerres
satisfaisante aujourd'hui puisque
plusieurs études constatent un
détournement de ce seuil si la mesure
proposée à l'Assemblée consiste
uniquement à légaliser les ristournes
qui dépassent le seuil de 17% pourquoi
pas mais comment être certain que les
coopérations commerciales
apparaîtront réellement surtout aucune
étude ou évaluation n'a pu être fourni
sur l'impact d'un relèvement de seuil
qui ne serait accompagné d'aucune autre
mesure en parallèle que ce soit en terme
d'approvisionnement ou de production
industrielle ou de partage des gains
pour l'assurance maladie c'est pourquoi
notre Commission a proposé à ce stade
d'en rester au texte initial du
gouvernement qui met en place un
dispositif de déclaration permettant de
diminuer les prix publics des
médicaments je saisis l'occasion de ce
sujet car avec plusieurs autres dans ce
plfs il soulève une même question nous
avons tous été alertés sur les
éventuelles conséquences de la fixation
d'un plafond de prise en charge par les
contrats complémentaires j'en ai parlé
que ce soit pour les médicaments les
lunettes les prothèses dentaires les
appareils d'audioprothèses
quelle est la répartition optimale des
marges entre les différents acteurs de
la chaîne de soins
quels niveaux de transparence doit
s'appliquer sur les prix alors même que
la collectivité sécurité sociale ou
couverture complémentaire on solvabise
sur la bise une large part le
consommateur doit-il savoir combien le
chirurgien-dentiste a acheté une
prothèse combien l'opticien a acheté des
Verts combien le pharmacien a acheté le
médicament combien coûte le dispositif
médical mise en place par un
professionnel nous avions déjà eu ce
débat passionné au sujet des prothèses
dentaires je crois qu'il se pose
aujourd'hui de la même manière et avec
la même acuité pour l'optique voir le
médicament me semble donc madame la
ministre qui serait particulièrement
intéressant de lancer une mission sur ce
sujet Comment rétribuer de manière juste
l'ensemble des acteurs du fabricant ou
revendeurs final pour à la fois
favoriser la production dans notre pays
et ne pas peser trop lourdement sur les
finances de nos concitoyens et sur les
comptes publics la transparence dans la
formation des prix et des marges peut
constituer à mon sens une porte d'entrée
intéressante pour éclairer cette
question mais nous voyons bien que nous
devrons revenir sur ces sujets
en conclusion le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 a comme priorité la consolidation
de la solidarité nationale qui constitue
la base de notre protection sociale
redressement durable des comptes sans
pour autant créer des faits
déflationnistes réforme de l'assurance
vieillesse et de la politique familiale
stratégie nationale de santé fondée sur
la proximité et la prévention tels sont
les éléments déterminants de ce texte
que la commission des affaires sociales
du Sénat à approuvé et vous demande
d'adopter je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à Monsieur Georges la Bazire
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales pour le secteur médico-social
madame la Présidente c'est le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues en tant que rapporteur
du volet médico-social du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2014
je tiens à saluer la progression des
crédits qui seront alloués à ce secteur
en 2014 avec une hausse de 3% London
médico-social
connaît-il progression certes moins
marquée que les années précédentes mais
plus dynamique que celle de London dans
son ensemble
si l'on ajoute à cette enveloppe
les ressources propres que mobilisera la
CNSA
18,8 milliards d'euros seront consacrés
l'année prochaine au financement des
établissements et services médicaux
sociaux
9,5 milliards d'euros seront dédiés au
secteur des personnes âgées des
personnes handicapées pardon et 9,3
milliards d'euros à celui des personnes
âgées
l'objectif
global de dépenses le GD sera en outre
abondé par un prélèvement de 70 millions
d'euros
effectués sur les réserves de la CNS
ces crédits supplémentaires permettront
de renforcer les moyens existants dans
les établissements et services médicaux
sociaux de remplir les objectifs de
création de place fixées par les
différents plans gouvernementaux et de
poursuivre la médicalisation des EHPAD
sur ce point il faut noter qu'à la fin
de l'année 2012
31% des établissements soit
20% des places n'était pas encore passé
à un mode de tarification définie en
fonction du GIR moyen pondéré soins
des efforts substantiels devront donc
encore être réalisé dans les années à
venir pour achever ce processus
en 2014 15 millions d'euros vont être
plus spécifiquement consacrés à
l'achèvement du plan Alzheimer
le rapport d'évaluation qui a été publié
au mois de juin dernier constitue une
base de travail solide pour conforter et
améliorer les structures crées dans le
cadre du Plan je pense en particulier
vous l'avez souligné madame la ministre
aux maisons pour l'autonomie et
l'intégration des malades d'Alzheimer
les fameuses de Mayas comme c'est engagé
le président de la République le plan
doit être étendu à l'ensemble des
maladies neurones dégénératrices
je formule le souhait que la dynamique
engagée avait le premier plan puisse
être maintenu voire amplifier rapidement
dans les années à venir
au cours des années passées
les rapporteurs pour le secteur
médico-social
on fréquemment regretté la
sous-consommation de l'ogv personnes
âgées qui a été de
189 millions d'euros en 2012 et devrait
encore s'élever à 150 millions d'euros
en 2013
le directeur de la CNSA que nous avons
rencontré lors des entretiens me l'a
assuré ce problème sera bientôt derrière
nous grâce à resserrement du calendrier
budgétaire et aux améliorations
apportées au suivi des crédits ainsi
qu'à leur modalités d'allocation pour
les créations de places effectivement
les tarifications qui se déroulent au
mois de
pour l'annonce antarification du mois de
juin seront rapidement avancées au mois
de mars qui permet disons une meilleure
gestion je reste en tout cas attentif
à ce que les enveloppes sur lesquels se
prononcent chaque année le Parlement
puisse être effectivement consommé dans
des conditions satisfaisantes
à ce titre il m'a semblé nécessaire
d'améliorer le degré d'information dont
dispose la représentation nationale
concernant le financement des
établissements et services
médico-sociaux
le gouvernement à l'obligation de
transvettre au Parlement chaque année
avant le 15 septembre un rapport sur le
financement des établissements de santé
qui lorsqu'il est communiqué dans les
temps constituent un support
utile à l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale rien
n'existe dans le secteur médico-social
alors même que les règles de financement
y sont à la fois hétérogènes et complexe
à mon initiative la Commission a donc
adopté un amendement tendante à
introduire dans le code de l'action
sociale et des familles un article qui
constituera le pendant
pour les établissements et services
financés par London
médico-social des dispositions du code
de la sécurité sociale relative au
rapport annuel sur le financement des
établissements de santé
en début de navette un seul article du
projet de loi était consacré au secteur
médico-social il s'agit comme chaque
année depuis la loi de financement pour
d'affecter une partie du produit de la
contribution de solidarité pour
l'autonomie au financement du plan
d'aide à l'investissement ce que nous
appelons couramment le pays pour 2014 ce
sont 2% qui doivent être consacrés sont
un peu moins de 30 millions d'euros
chaque année les crédits alloués au pai
sont gelées au titre des mesures de
régulation de long dedans
ils sont ensuite abondés en cours
d'exercice budgétaire à partir des
réserves de la CNSA
si la meilleure consommation de l'OGD se
confirme dans les années à venir les
ressources de la CNSA ne permettront
bientôt plus de compenser ces mesures de
gel
grâce au pays la CNSA apporte un soutien
indispensable pour le financement des
investissements réalisés par les
structures médico-sociales
en effet ces crédits sécurisent l'accès
à l'emprunt et contribuer et contribue à
limiter le poids de l'investissement
dans les tarifs appliqués par les
établissements donc nécessairement un
allègement du prix du journée à outre
les besoins de modernisation et de
remise aux normes du parc des gens
importants sont amenés à augmenter
fortement dans les années à venir en
raison de vieillissement de celui-ci
nous pouvons estimer à l'heure actuelle
avec des situations différentes madame
la ministre selon les départements qu'à
peu près 40% du parc des EHPAD des
maisons de retraite si on les appelle
ainsi plus communément sont disons dans
l'obligation d'être rénové ce qui
représente des sommes très très
importantes et pour lesquelles les
départements ne peuvent
un seul assumer
la Commission a donc adopté sur ma
proposition un amendement visant à mieux
identifier et sécuriser les crédits
destinés au pai au sein du budget de la
CNS au moins 2% du produit de la CSA lui
seront désormais affectés de façon
pérenne au sein d'une nouvelle section
dédiée à l'investissement
la semaine nationale a introduit une
article additionnelle qui a pour objet
de mettre fin à l'expérimentation de la
modulation du forfait soin dans les
EHPAD en fonction des indicateurs de
qualité et déficiente
dès l'examen de la loi de financement
pour 2012 qui crée cette expérimentation
notre collègue Renan cadran avait
demandé sa suppression
soulignant les incertitudes qui
caractérisent la tarification des EHPAD
et la jugeant par conséquent prématuré
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales je me félicite donc de cette
convergence de vue entre nos deux
assemblées tout en regrettant les
blocages qui continuent d'empêcher toute
clarification du système de financement
des EHPAD je pense en particulier à la
tarification à la ressource prévue par
la loi des financements pour du business
mais il est toujours pas entré en
vigueur faute de décret
un tel manque de visibilité est
regrettable
d'autant plus qu'un homme non
négligeable d'établissement seront
amenés à renouveler leur convention
tripartite dans les prochaines années
une refonte de la tarification des
établissements pour personnes
handicapées viennent d'être engagés dans
le cadre de la modernisation de l'action
publique et même la ministre nous en
réjouissons il s'agit d'un processus
ambitieux qui a vocation à se dérouler
sur plusieurs années je souhaite
vivement qu'il puisse être une source
d'inspiration pour réfléchir à des
évolutions claires et consensuelles dans
le secteur des personnes âgées
voilà
mesdames les ministres monsieur le
ministre de sa collègue les principales
observations que je souhaitais formuler
sur le volet médico-social de ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale dans un contexte où l'effort de
redressement de nos comptes sociaux doit
être partagé par tous le soutien à
l'autonomie des personnes âgées
handicapées demeurent une priorité du
gouvernement j'en suis heureux et je le
suis d'autant plus que depuis
l'intervention du Premier ministre le 14
octobre dernier confirmé tout à l'heure
par vous madame la ministre ici la
tribune du Sénat nous connaissons le
contour et le calendrier de la future
réforme sur l'adaptation de la société
obéissement
son premier volet qui doit être adopté
l'ici la fin de l'année prochaine sera
centrée sur la prise en charge au
domicile
la réforme de la part en constituera
l'un des points majeurs dans un contexte
où plus du quart des plans d'aide
élaborés par les bénéficiaires de la pas
domicile sont toujours dit saturés elle
devra permettre de mieux prendre en
compte les besoins des personnes les
plus dépendantes
cette réforme sera également
indissociable d'une réflexion sur le
financement de la part
qui repose aujourd'hui très largement je
dirais trop largement sur les
départements depuis
2002 où la part de l'État et la part des
départements était à parité 55 ans nous
sommes passés en disant
sur une part de 28% de l'État et 72%
du des départements je sais que le
gouvernement travaille
allait soutenir dans le financement des
différents allocations individuelles de
solidarité on aura l'occasion je crois
d'en discuter lors du projet de loi de
finances il est à ce titre indispensable
que des garanties puissent être
apportées au département quand un
partage équitable de financement de
l'appât dans les années à venir
le second volet qui sera mis en oeuvre
ultérieurement portera sur la prise en
charge en établissement et devra
notamment traiter de la lourde question
du reste à charge acquitté par les
résidents
sur ce point il me semble essentiel de
travailler sur la base d'un diagnostic
étayer des différents coûts que
supportent les personnes hébergées en
établissement à la refonte des
dispositifs d'aide qui sont aujourd'hui
insuffisamment coordonnées et trop peu
redistribuer
nous le savons cette réforme ne pourrait
être réellement ambitieuse qu'à la
condition de s'enfuyer sur des
financements suffisant le Premier
ministre de nous rassurer madame la
ministre vous venez
d'y revenir dessus le produit de
la Casa lui sera entièrement consacré à
partir de 2015 c'est heureux mais je
l'aurais été davantage si comme cela
avait été prévu initialement par le
gouvernement la Casa avait été mise en
réserve dès 2013 au sein d'une section
dédiée au budget de la CNS
de cette façon nous aurions été en
mesure de mobiliser dès le début de
l'année 2015 un peu plus de milliards
d'euros or la Casa a été entièrement
redirigé en 2014 pour alimenter le fond
de solidarité vieillesse c'est de mesure
qui ne devait être exceptionnelle a été
réfléchi en 2014 même comme vous l'avez
annoncé si grâce un amendement adopté
par la semelle nationale 100 millions de
cent millions d'euros resteront affectés
à la CNS
il me semble qu'il aurait été plus
lisible et plus compréhensible pour nos
concitoyens que cette contribution qui
pèse sur les retraités études dès
l'origine une vocation clairement
assumée je reste pendant optimiste
depuis plusieurs années sur l'ensemble
des bancs de cette hémicycle nous
attendons cette réforme de l'adaptation
de la société au vieillissement
aujourd'hui nous avons des certitudes un
cas clair a été fixé la concertation va
être engagée dans les prochains jours je
souhaite qu'elle puisse aboutir
rapidement et que 2014 soit une année
porteuse d'un espoir renouvelé pour les
personnes en situation de perte
d'autonomie pour leurs proches ainsi que
pour l'ensemble des professionnels qui
les accompagnent chaque jour je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à madame Isabelle Pasquier
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales pour la famille
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues
en 2013 pour la 6e année consécutive la
branche famille afficherait un niveau
élevé de difficile
2,8 milliards d'euros ce triste record
le dernier remonté à 2010 s'explique par
un ralentissement marqué des recettes
lui-même imputable à la mauvaise
conjoncture économique cette dégradation
est toutefois moins importante que celle
prévue initialement grâce aux milliards
d'euros de recettes supplémentaires
affectés à la branche par la loi de
finance rectificative doute 2012 et la
loi de finances membre de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 ce que j'avais alors
qualifié de bouffées d'oxygène a mis fin
à une fragilisation sans précédentes de
recettes de la branche opérée sous le
précédent quinquennat dans le transfert
de 0,28 points de 16g vers la Cadès en
2011 a été la mesure la plus
emblématique
je souligne à ce sujet que le rendement
des trois taxes affectés à la CNAF en
contrepartie de cette perte de CSG ne
cesse de diminuer d'année en année
malgré les efforts entrepris l'année
dernière en recettes le déficit de la
branche continuerait de se creuser en
2014 pour atteindre les 3,3 milliards
d'euros pour éviter ce dérapage le
présent projet de loi de financement
prévoit un nouveau transfert de recettes
à la branche famille pour un montant de
1 milliard qui permettrait de ramener le
déficit à 2,3 milliards ce milliard
d'euros supplémentaire provient de
l'affectation à la CNAV du gain
financier attendu de la baisse du
plafond du quotient familial de 2000 à
1500 euros par demi part mesure prévu à
l'article 3 du projet de loi de finances
pour 2014 environ 1,3 millions de foyers
seront concernés par cette abaissement
du plafond soit 12% des ménages
la CNAF se voit également attribuer la
compensation de la perte de 0,15 point
de cotisation patronale famille soit
1,16 milliards d'euros destiné à assurer
la neutralité de l'augmentation des
cotisations patronales vieillesse sur le
coût du travail
la rétrocession à la branche famille des
économies escomptés de la réforme du
quotient familial et la compensation de
la diminution des cotisations patronales
familles pour un montant total d'environ
2,19 milliards d'euros repose sur un
schéma de financement pour le moins
complexe le dispositif retenu comprend
en effet deux étapes tout d'abord un
transfert de recettes du budget de
l'État vers la sécurité sociale au moyen
d'un accroissement de la fraction du
produit de la TVA affecté à la CNAM
ensuite l'attribution à la cnaval d'un
panier de recettes en provenance de la
CNAV composé de divers impôts et taxes
bien sûr on ne peut que partager
l'objectif du gouvernement de Red de
redressement des comptes de la branche
famille
je considère cependant que les
modifications apportées par le PLF et le
pdfss pour 2014 en matière de recettes
remettent profondément en cause son
financement solidaire qui repose
historiquement sur les cotisations
sociales
l'affectation du produit de
l'abaissement du plafond du concert
familial et surtout le remplacement
d'une part des cotisations familiales
patronales famille par des impôts et
taxes sont à mes yeux révélateurs d'un
basculement vers un financement
fiscalisé dont les premiers
contributeurs sont les ménages je crains
par ailleurs que ce nouveau montage
financier outre le fait qu'il
complexifie encore un peu plus la
structure de financement de la branche
n'offre n'offre pas les garanties
suffisantes qu'un quant à son
financement pérenne
enfin il est particulièrement
regrettable que la recette
supplémentaire occasionnée par la
fiscalisation de la majoration de
pensions pour trois enfants et plus
mesure prévues à l'article 6 du PLF soit
affecté au financement de la réforme des
retraites plutôt qu'à la banche famille
alors que c'est elle qui supporte la
charge de cette prestation pour le
compte du fond de solidarité vieillesse
depuis 2009 une deuxième injustice qui
s'ajoute à celle qui consiste à élargir
l'assiette de l'impôt sur le revenu des
familles et donc diminuer leur pouvoir
d'achat déjà largement impacté par les
effets de la crise
les mesures familles inscrites en
dépensons quant à elle la traduction
législative des annonces faites par le
Premier ministre le 3 juin dernier à
l'occasion de la rénovation de la
politique familiale deux objectifs
étaient annoncés
l'amélioration du caractère
redistributif du système actuel en
ciblant certaines prestations sur les
familles en ayant le plus besoin et la
participation au redressement financier
de la branche en lui faisant réaliser
des économies l'intention est certes
Louane mais ces objectifs remettent en
cause le principe auquel je suis
profondément attaché d’universalité des
prestations familiales en outre il
s'inscrivent clairement dans une logique
d'austérité que je ne peux cautionner
la première mesure consiste un une
majoration du complément familial à 50%
sur 5 ans pour les familles vivantes
sous le seuil de pauvreté
conformément à l'engagement pris dans le
cadre du plan plurianuel contre la
pauvreté pour l'inclusion sociale cette
majoration qui devrait bénéficier à 400
000 familles il va de pairs avec celles
annoncé de la location de soutien
familial de 25% à l'horizon 2018
la deuxième mesure et la modulation du
montant de la location de base de la
prestation d'accueil du jeune enfant la
page selon le niveau de ressources des
familles ces bénéficiaires définis comme
les plus aisés verront son diminués de
moitié tandis que ces bénéficiaires les
plus modestes continueront de le
percevoir à taux plein 10% des familles
éligibles soient 180 000 d'entre elles
percevront désormais la location de base
à taux partiel la troisième mesure
concerne la majoration du complément de
libre choix d'activité le CL la CLCA qui
ont le C mais favorable aux familles
dite les plus aisées afin que tous les
allocataires quel que soit le niveau de
leurs ressource perçoivent un montant de
CLCA identiques il est proposé de
supprimer cette majoration
enfin la quatrième mesure instaure à
mécanisme de plafonnement des tarifs
pratiqués par les micro-crèches il
ressort en effet d'une enquête réalisée
par la CNAV fin 2012 que certaines de
ces structures ont recours à des
pratiques abusives du fait de la liberté
tarifaire dont elle bénéficie le
dispositif prévu qui repose sur le
complément de mode de garde versée aux
familles utilisatrices conduirait à une
limitation des tarifs facturés donc
diminution du reste à charge des
familles
trois autres dispositions relèvent à mon
sens ni plus ni moins de la rigueur
budgétaire
la non revalorisation du montant de la
location de base de la page jusqu'à ce
que le montant du complément familial
régulièrement revaloriser selon les
règles de droits communs atteignent le
même niveau le rattrapage entre ces
prestations est imprévu pour 2020 cela
signifie que le montant de la location
de base n'évoluera pas pendant 6 années
consécutives à ce gel s'ajoute celui des
montants des primes à la naissance et à
l'adoption la location de logements
familial subira le même sort l'année
prochaine de même que la location de
logements sociales et l'aide
personnalisée au logement dans le
contexte économique et social que nous
connaissons ces mesures vont pénaliser
encore un peu plus les familles les plus
fragiles
c'est d'autant plus incompréhensible que
vous êtes mettez-vous même dans l'étude
d'impact que l'augmentation des aides au
logement est lié à la mauvaise
conjoncture économique et à la hausse du
chômage en somme plus il y a de besoin
plus on contracte les budgets quelques
mots pour finir sur la nouvelle
convention d'objectifs et de gestion
signé entre la CNAV et l'État le 16
juillet dernier après plus d'un an et
demi de négociation longue et difficile
et sur laquelle j'ai pu m'entretenir
avec les représentants syndicaux des
salariés des cafs les deux premières
orientations stratégiques retenues de
développement des services aux familles
et l'amélioration de l'accès aux droits
me semble pertinente elle s'accompagne
d'ailleurs d'une augmentation de
significative des crédits du Front
national d'action sociale sur la période
2013-2017
en revanche le troisième axe qui vise un
choc de production selon les termes même
de la Convention ne résoudra en rien la
profonde de crise que traverse les caves
depuis deux ans maintenant au contraire
il risque de l'aggraver en raison des
économies de gestion qu'il prévoit alors
que la cause repose sur un renforcement
des moyens humains des caisses sur les
deux premières années à hauteur de 700
et équivalentin il en est il est dans le
même temps acté que les effectifs du
réseau devront diminuer 2000 équivalent
en plein en 5 ans autrement dit on
reprend d'une main ce que l'on donne de
l'autre en résumé madame la ministre je
crains que ce pdfss fasse un pas de plus
vers la remise en question de la branche
famille et ce malgré les diverses
déclarations l'approche que vous avez de
la redistribution pose plusieurs
problèmes d'abord plus un soumet les
prestations en ressources plus on
s'éloigne de l'universalité sans compter
que les dossiers vont voir leur
traitement se complexifier ce qui va à
l'encontre du choc de simplification
réclamé par le Président de la
République et aux économies de gestion
que l'on demande aux caisses de faire
deuxièmement on prend aux zinc pour
donner aux autres au classe moyenne pour
donner au plus modeste ou même parfois
personne selon le cas il serait plus
pertinent me semble-t-il pour combler
les inégalités d'engager une grande
réforme de la fiscalité pour rendre
l'impôt plus juste et plus progressif
qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
de plus le budget de la page famille
sert largement la politique de lutte
contre la pauvreté loin de moi l'idée
qu'elle ne doit pas y contribuer mais ce
n'est pas sa vocation première et puis
recentrer les prestations sur les
ménages les plus modestes au détriment
des autres risque de renforcer la
stigmatisation déjà existante des plus
démunis tout cela bien sûr pose la
question du financement de la branche
car si on la détourne de sa vocation
première on est amené évidemment à
s'interroger pour savoir qui la finance
et comment on la finance à ce titre je
rappelle que les prestations familiales
font partie du salaire socialisé et en
conséquence toute remise en cause le gel
ou la baisse des cotisations sociales
équivaut à une baisse des salaires et
donc une perte de pouvoir d'achat
tous ces doutes et ces craintes
m'amènent vous l'aurez compris apporter
un avis défavorable sur ce PLFSS un avis
je tiens le dire qui est partagé par une
majorité d'organismes sociaux
associations et syndicats je vous
remercie
merci Madame rapporteur la parole est à
Madame Christiane de montaix rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
pour l'assurance vieillesse
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues
s'agissant de la branche vieillesse
évidemment le PLFSS pour 2014 et madame
la ministre l'a indiqué dans son propos
introductif s'inscrit bien entendu dans
le prolongement du projet de loi
garantissant l'avenir et la justice de
notre système de retraite en cours
d'examen au Parlement et nous étions la
semaine dernière à la mémoire toujours
en discussion sur ce projet de loi
retraite vous le savez mais je vais vous
le rappeler ce projet de loi s'articule
autour de trois axes principaux le
redressement des comptes des régimes de
retraite à court terme et la correction
de la trajectoire financière de long
terme la priorité donnée à l'équité qui
exige de mieux prendre en compte les
évolutions sociales et la diversité des
parcours professionnels dans
l'acquisition des droits à la retraite
notamment pour les femmes et les nous
donne de nos concitoyens enfin le
renforcement du droit à l'information
des assurés et l'amélioration de la
coordination entre les régimes le PLFSS
ne comporte donc pas de mesures de fond
ou de dépenses nouvelles
concernant bien évidemment la branche
vieillesse mais il traduit l'équilibre
financier de la réforme et accompagne
les mesures d'équité dont nous avons
débattu nos discussions relatives au
projet de loi sur les retraites ayant
été longues et nourries je me limiterais
à rappeler en quelques mots la
contribution de cette réforme à
l'amélioration de la situation
financière de l'assurance vieillesse
l'effort de redressement de notre
système de retraite a été engagé dès
l'été 2012 avec les mesures de recettes
portées par le décret de juillet 2012 et
par la loi de finances rectificative 12
doutes pardon 2012 cette année ces
mesures ont joué sur une année pleine
conjuguée aux mesures inscrites dans la
financement de la sécurité sociale et la
loi de finances pour 2013 elles ont
largement contribué à la réduction des
déficits au total le déficit de
l'ensemble de la branche vieillesse et
du Fonds de solidarité vieillesse le FSV
sera en effet réduit de plus d'un tiers
entre 2012 et 2013 passant de 10,2
milliards d'euros à 6,8 milliards
d'euros les mesures de financement
contenues dans le projet de loi sur les
retraites prolonge ses efforts j'ai déjà
eu de l'occasion de souligner que ces
mesures mettent à concitribution
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens les actifs
les employeurs et les retraités sur la
base des formes modérés et équitablement
répartis et dans des conditions
d'anticipation raisonnables vous le
savez à court terme la contribution des
actifs et des employeurs monsieur le
ministre du Budget l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure se traduira par une progressive
de 0,3 points en 4 ans des cotisations
d'assurance vieillesse s'agissant des
retraités la date de revalorisation des
pensions de retraite sera reportée de 6
mois et cette mesure ne s'appliquera ni
à la location de solidarité aux
personnes âgées la SPA ni au rente liée
aux accidents du travail et aux maladies
professionnelles la branche ATMP dans
mon collègue Godefroy parlera après moi
la réforme des retraites prévoit
également des économies de gestion des
régimes de retraite à cet égard les
objectifs précis à signer à la CNAV la
Caisse nationale d'assurance vieillesse
et à la Caisse nationale de retraite des
agents des collectivités locales feront
l'objet des prochaines conventes de
prochaines conventions d'objectifs
d'objectifs pardon et de gestion qui
seront signés avec l'État
l'impact total des mesures de
financement contenues dans la réforme
s'élèvera ainsi à milliard d'euros en
2014 et le déficit de la branche
vieillesse de l'ensemble des régimes de
base devrait être ramenés en 2014 à 1,6
milliards d'euros en ce qui concerne le
déficit de la branche vieillesse du sol
régime général il devrait atteindre 1,2
milliards d'euros au lieu de 3,7
milliards d'euros s'il n'y avait pas eu
de réformes sur la trajectoire du retour
à l'équilibre des régimes de base à
l'horizon 2020 la résorption du déficit
de la branche vieillesse du régime
général est envisagée pour 2016 un
dernier mot pour souligner que la
troisième partie du PLF 16 relative aux
recettes et à l'équilibre financier
comporte trois articles qui font
directement écho au projet de loi sur
les retraites premièrement afin de
financer les mesures d'équité en faveur
des petites pensions agricoles l'article
9 augmente les recettes de la branche
vieillesse du régime des exploitants
agricoles par la suppression d'une niche
sociale deuxièmement l'article 10 crée
une cotisation vieillesse des plafonnée
au régime social des indépendants le RSI
pour permettre une hausse des
cotisations dans des termes
identiques à l'ensemble des régimes de
base et enfin l'article 16 prévoit les
conditions dans lesquelles l'état
compensera les exonérations de
cotisations vieillesse des apprentis qui
pourront désormais valider l'ensemble de
leur trimestre d'apprentissage au titre
de la retraite monsieur le Président
Mesdames les ministres Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues le PLFSS pour 2014 poursuit
résolument le redressement des comptes
amorcés en 2012 il répond ainsi à la
double exigence de financement et de
justice inscrite au cœur de la réforme
en cours d'examen je vous remercie
madame de montesse la parole est à
Monsieur jean-Pierre Godefroy rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
pour les accidents du travail et les
maladies professionnelles
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
la branche ATMP du régime général
devrait clore l'un des 2013 avec un
excellent de 300 millions d'euros
excédent que l'on constate à nouveau en
2014 mais pour moins de 70 millions
d'euros
la situation de la branche est donc
fragile d'autant qu'elle doit rembourser
une dette de plus de 2 milliards d'euros
actuellement porté par la cosse
ceci nous a ceci nous incite une
vigilance particulière sur les moyens
dont elle dispose et sur les charges
qu'elle supporte
l'essentiel des charges est liée aux
dépenses de réparation de trois types de
sinistre que couvre la branche les
accidents du travail les accidents de
trajet et les maladies professionnelles
on peut noter avec satisfaction que le
nombre d'accidents du travail en 2012 a
atteint un niveau historiquement bas
avec moins de 950 000 sinistres recensés
cette baisse est réelle car elle se
traduit tant par une baisse de
l'incidence des fréquences que 35
accidents pour 1000 salariés que de la
gravité on peut cependant regretter
comme l'année dernière que les
statistiques présentées par la Direction
de la Sécurité Sociale ne couvre que les
salariés du régime général elles
laissent dans l'ombre la situation des
agriculteurs exploitant et salariés et
de la fonction publique
le regroupement des données des régimes
de sécurité sociale pour construire des
indicateurs de surveillance commun
restent l'être morte faute de
financement de la part de l'Assurance
Maladie pourriez-vous madame la ministre
incité la CNAM TS a bouclé le tour de
table mis en place par l'Institut de
veille sanitaire
les accidents de trajet connaissent une
baisse significative en 2012 mais reste
au-delà du niveau de 2008 il me semble
que analyse plus détaillée de ces des
causes de ses accidents et nécessaires
les explications actuellement proposées
à savoir l'influence du climat sur
l'évaluation de la sinistralité sont peu
satisfaisantes surtout quand on prend en
compte le fait que le trajet est un
facteur de stress en lien direct avec
les risques psychosociaux enfin le
nombre de maladies professionnelles
baissent également par rapport au picata
en 2011 mais sans retrouver le niveau de
2010 le nombre de personnes atteintes de
maladies professionnelles progresse de
5% en moyenne chaque année depuis 2007
et une par croissante d'entre elles
souffrent de polypathologies
si on prend en compte le fait qu'une
partie de la baisse de la sinistralité
en 2012 est imputable à la conjoncture
économique et un faible croissance de la
masse salariale la situation du monde du
travail au regard des risques accidents
du travail accident de trajet et maladie
professionnelle apparaît comme fragile
il est d'ailleurs à noter que la France
est toujours au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne
ceci ne doit pas aboutir à minimiser les
progrès déjà accomplis notamment pour la
prévention des actions du travail dans
les branches les plus accidentogènes
comme le bâtiment mais ce diagnostic
doit nous amener à soutenir la volonté
commune j'insiste sur ce point des
partenaires sociaux à rompre avec la
logique de la simple réparation des
dommages pour s'engager pleinement dans
une optique de prévention tant à faire
disparaître les risques ou au moins à
protéger le mieux possible et salarié la
signature prévue fin novembre de la
nouvelle convention d'objectifs et de
gestion de la branche pour la période
2014 2017 doit marquer cette
réorientation qu'il est en fait qu'un
retour aux principes de la loi du 30
octobre 1946 intégrant à la sécurité
sociale le régime fondé en 1898
dès lors les réductions d'effectifs
prévues dans les carsats et l'Institut
national de recherche et de sécurité
pour la prévention des accidents du
travail et des maladies professionnelles
l'INRS crée en 1947 ne peuvent que nous
inquiéter
s'il est nécessaire de dégager des
marges de productivité il ne peut être
question selon nous de réduire les
postes affectés aux actions de
prévention et à la recherche pouvez-vous
nous préciser madame la ministre quels
sont les intentions du Gouvernement en
la matière
la faiblesse des marges de manoeuvre
financière de la branche risque de
limiter sa capacité à mettre en oeuvre
un budget constant ces actions de
prévention or une augmentation des
cotisations patronales n'est pas où les
plus envisageable à court et moyen terme
en effet l'adoption du compte de
pénibilité s'il est adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale créera
parallèlement à la branche ATMP un
nouveau distique dispositif avec un mode
de financement très similaire vous avez
madame la ministre indiqué lors de votre
audition à l'Assemblée nationale que le
compte de prévention de la pénibilité
impactera la branche ATMP pourriez nous
nous apporter des précisions à ce sujet
la fragilité financière de la branche
impose expliqué l'augmentation
importante de la dotation au FIVA
c'est un chapitre très important
435 millions d'euros 435 millions
d'euros cette année contre 115 l'année
dernière et 320 millions en moyenne sur
les années précédentes
il ne fait aucun doute que le FIVA a
besoin des sommes qui sont affectés
l'évolution de ces charges telle qu'elle
avait été se présenter en 2012 c'est
avéré largement sous-estimé au point que
le conseil d'administration du fond a dû
voter en octobre dernier un budget
complémentaire d'urgence de 100 millions
d'euros puisés dans son fond de
roulement
celui-ci atteint désormais moins de la
moitié de la réserve prudentielle si les
charges utiva augmentent c'est
principalement parce que les dossiers
des victimes et de leurs ayant droit
sont réglés plus rapidement et c'est là
un point positif il le serait donc être
question de réduire la dotation de la
branche ATMP néanmoins madame la
ministre l'absence totale de dotation de
l'État au FIVA en 2014 ne nous paraît
pas acceptable
si elle pouvait à la rigueur se
justifier l'année dernière le contexte
financier du fond a on l'a vu
complètement changé dès lors l'absence
de dotation qui est contraire au texte
consultés constitutifs du fivain et qui
revêt de surcroît une forte dimension
symbolique du fait de la double
responsabilité de l'État dans l'affaire
de l'amiante en tant qu'employeur et en
tant que régulateur ne peut être
cautionné j'estime qu'elle fait courir
un risque un risque non négligeable
d'insuffisance de dotation budgétaire
globale du fond en 2014 je me
concentrerai donc avec le rapporteur de
la mission santé et les membres du
groupe de suivi du rapport de notre
commission sur l'amiante pour envisager
un amendement lors du projet de loi de
finances
nous quittons à l'hémicycle du Sénat
mais nous reviendrons bien entendu à 19h
sur les enjeux de cette séance consacrée
je vous le rappelle au projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ce
sera le débat du 24 heures Sénat à 19h
mais tout de suite l'émission politique
de la rédaction de Public Sénat preuve
par 3 qui reçoit ce soir l'ancien
Premier ministre sénateur UMP de la
Vienne Jean-Pierre Raffarin bonne soirée
à tout à l'heure